hätten der regierung manchmal ganz
einfache bauernregeln auf die sprünge
geholfen in dieser im krise darüber
möchte ich sprechen mit einem mann der
politiker ist und bauer nämlich mit karl
heinz funke dem langjährigen
landwirtschaftsminister ich grüße sie
ganz herzlich herr funke nun
freundlichen grüßen zurück nach berlin
in unserer hauptstadt aus varel auf dem
platten land erwische ich sie gerade
sagen sie fällt ihnen eine bauernregel
ein die aktuell auf die lage auf dieses
impf desaster passten wir feld vor allen
dingen zum sogenannten impfgipfel ein
bei dem wir nichts rausgekommen ist wenn
der harn offen ist ändert sich das
wetter oder es bleibt wie es ist so
meine schulter sie waren als bauer als
landwirt jahre lang selbst in der
politik hat ihnen da die bauernschläue
ab und zu geholfen ihr natürlich
bauernschläue beruht ja auch erkenntnis
und erfahrung gleichen maß wie und diese
bauernschläue geht ja heute fielen in
der politik ab die kommen ja nicht mehr
aus der praxis die sind nicht mehr über
die kommunalpolitik in die politik in
die große politik hinein gewachsen
sondern ohne praktische lebenserfahrung
im landtag oder bundestag und das tut
entscheidung nicht gut dann machen wir
es doch mal konkret funk gefällt ihnen
was ein in diesem impfstoff desaster was
der bauer mit seiner lebenserfahrung mit
seiner praxiserfahrung anders gemacht
hätte der ball war ist wenn er bloß
kaufen will
was gut ist und was wichtig ist und was
er unbedingt gebraucht da muss er sich
mit dem wenn es sich zum beispiel um
eine erste maschine handelt kurzzeitig
beschäftigen muss abwägen welche
maschine für ihn die am tausendsten ist
dann weiß ja auch dass auch rechtzeitig
bestellen muss und dass er geld am tisch
liegen muss
da geht dann auch der alte satz wer
immer nur auf gutes wetter erwartet wird
genau da muss ich abwägen aber ich muss
auch wissen dass wir uns rechtzeitig
geschehen
wenn ich mich im juni juni beschäftigen
damit ob ich eine erntemaschine brauche
bist du spät gegessen
das macht der bauern jetzt im winter
ganz allgemeine einfache dinge die
kriegen oder um bauernhof im übrigen als
junge mit ich finde ja eine wichtige
bauernregel im moment eine wichtige
weisheit ist auch einfach mal vor der
eigenen türe kehren wenn es darum geht
verantwortung zu übernehmen wie kommt
das bei ihnen auf dem land an dieses
rausreden wegducken im moment ja nicht
erinnere mich an einen satz von herrn
sparenden fernsehen vor ein paar tagen
auf die frage wer denn nun verantwortung
habe wir haben alle verantwortung so
weit ein guter geist und im
plattdeutschen das müssen wir übersetzen
das müssen wir übersetzen herr funke
will nicht reife machen so was einem gut
tut und sich einen gut so das ist so das
heißt wenn eine verantwortung haben dann
hat letztlich keiner verantwortung es
wird hin und her geschoben und ich habe
die große vermutung ist jetzt etwas
kühlen was ich sage man heute der
kommission gerne die verantwortung für
die beschaffung der impfung übertragen
um nicht selbst die verantwortung
übernehmen zu müssen
das geht nicht nur jeder bauer weiß wenn
diese habe ich auch die verantwortung
dafür dass das hat nun aufgeht
ich muss sehen dass ich lernte da muss
ich mich kümmern und zwar selbst und
dann kann ich nicht immer zu anderen zur
nacht von kurzen gang der hut sein der
maschine aus dem schuppen und jetzt muss
ich auch mal meine maschine raus holen
und dann kommt er so naturparadies aber
kaputt die haben und letzten herz so weg
gestellt
dann ging es auf dem hof grad
und das auch zu recht
dieses fehlt gegenwärtig in meinen augen
völlig sich rechtzeitig um etwas kümmern
sich abstimmen aber auch antworten zu
übernehmen das heißt die ganze
darstellung die da heute passiert ist
mehr verschleierung als den tatsachen
ins auge zu kommen ganz einfache
weisheiten im umgang mit menschen
untereinander und der politik mit
menschen zu tun hat
gilt das auch wirklich ihrer politik
städtischen vielen dank an den
langjährigen in landwirtschaftsminister
und bauern karl heinz funke für mehr
bauernschläue im moment in dieser
impfstoff krise und eins ist da sie
haben gerade gesagt dann gab es krach
auf dem hof krach gibt es jetzt auch auf
dem hof bei der regierung auf jeden fall
wegen dieses immenstadt impfstoff
debakels danke herr funke schöne grüße
vom land berlin
die castingshow die kraft ging schon
immer vom lande auf